this is weird mageddon part two I'm back
and I'm loving it baby
I got dressed up there didn't you oh
yeah I got a unicorn
so we'll cuz like reality and yeah now
of course I was saying did Mable ever
wear a scarf but you pointed out this is
kind of specifically for cleavage
oh my God look at all this room I'm like
damn so I can rock some good man boobs
but that this ain't happenin so yeah um
when I makes it even more hilarious as
I've got an Evil Dead t-shirt on
underneath here there's the egg I feel
like uh somebody don't all balances out
you see somebody knitted a long time ago
knitted like a Mable a sweater patch
that like you knit into a sweater and I
just I've been having a hell of a time
finding I came from Arab I give you you
and I held on to you know you had it
okay anyway like I have it so that poor
girl who like frickin made that thing
for me and I feel sorry I'm like looking
everywhere for it and I can't I usually
don't lose stuff the bad thing I lost so
far so far oh that's okay gravity falls
has a long ways to go I'm sure we'll
find it before all the countless
episodes that they're gonna release we
should probably talk about that oh we
just found out well not just I mean we
found out maybe like we didn't I can't
even say anything to me the grief is
still too near well we found out a few
days ago I guess when everyone else
found out it looks just like Oh cuz we
literally just talked about this in the
last be long didn't we that oh if it
ends now we'd be okay and that we find
out we're like no so it's on the one
hand it's like okay leave them wanting
more I mean that makes sense it's a
smart thing to do but I just I want so
much more I mean like so much more I
would have been find with three seasons
yeah I feel like 3:00 would have been
right yeah like your idea of like the
spin-off where it's like then we get a
season in winter or a season in FAR's I
thought they'd love been really cool did
I a minute yeah no I thought the web man
really
yeah I remember that but you know maybe
go to a different place or not I don't
know but it's I don't know it's a we
can't be like angry cuz they're
definitely going out on top but it's
like ah I just I wanted so much more but
then again we did get so much um I mean
it's practically three seasons really uh
because they took so many hiatuses and
there's so many episodes I mean there's
seasons and shows are like what eleven
episodes and these are something like
you know twenty per season something
like that I mean so they're good runs
um but yeah just three three seasons
would have been perfect yes I always I
always aspired season three is real and
we still out always go out on top so
they're certainly doing that don't
overstay your welcome I mean it's not
like fucking Simpsons which should have
been over more than ten years ago um so
it I just want to just no more yes the
little just yet is that one of the
things where it's like oh I just needed
a little bit more it's like I want a lot
more
oh but to their credit tying into this
episode now seeing all the things that
they've done I will kind of admit I feel
like I'm seeing everything I wanted to
see out of this show like Mabel land
like fuckin own innate and forever you
know they've been building up this idea
cuz she has such a big personality such
a creative like well it's hurting my
eyes yes there's colors here that only
bees and art students can see maybe my
favorite wine it's the UH and it's a
great place to be after all like the
really dark twisted creepy stuff in the
last episode which was also wonderful uh
you know you see why they need so much
time on some of these episodes because I
mean these worlds they created I mean
and the background the background art
and this was Fant
yeah and just all the creative creatures
that I know are from like a lot of past
episodes but they had to make up a lot
of them too and on top of that be really
really funny and also very heartfelt and
meaningful I like sort of a fancy versus
reality trial that they're having and I
always feel like every direction I
didn't know I wanted it to go it usually
goes like you know when they're there
and it's like dipper you must be cast
out
no no we must have a trial and some
yummy oh yeah it's immediately like this
is a trial cats are in fact curious meow
meows it's like I didn't know I wanted
to see a trial that's a yes oh they
sound like yes yes I want to see this I
so want to see what a trial Maple Lane
it's like it's like a trial Wonderland
it's gonna be hilarious uh and it was um
and I like the fact cuz I saw that they
were gonna have Jon Stewart as a voice I
like the fact that they didn't have him
just come in and be Jon Stewart talking
oh he had a distinct voice on an accent
like you wouldn't even know it was it
was amusing yeah you know some young
music a music very amusing
y'all allow it I guess he did a good job
just making yummy al funny cats are
notoriously curious yeah um so yeah
obviously the creativity in there is
great I even though we've has seen these
stories before like these perfect
fantasy worlds are gonna give you
everything you want but it's not real so
you have to fight it ah they're done so
many times because there is so much you
can say about a character attached of
personality and you want to see
everyone's interpretation of it it's all
about I won't execute it yeah so and I
thought this was executed pretty
flawlessly because if ever there was
something that I wanted to see inside
somebody's head it's definitely Mabel's
yeah it's you know no one else when did
you not disappoint it well whether it be
like dipper or Stan's or Wendy's or
somebody's like nobody else would you be
like oh I want to see what that world
looks like need for a second but you get
tired of it pretty quick like Mabel's
the only one were you like yes let's see
what this would look like and so it's
smart that they stuck with that world
and they'd still had the temptations
with the other characters I thought the
one with the waffle guards yeah I'm
waiting for this moment somebody get me
some syrup
I thought the temptation for Sue's those
particularly satellite chickweed
so what we're hearing manapouri Lucia it
was very poignant and yeah that just
what an indictment of deadbeat dads and
a good deal 5 seconds so like that's all
you need it's like wow that is that is
so sad well they had a lipo so de kado -
yeah but I mean he was a great way to
just bring it back up again without it
just five seconds you're like wow
that's see the funny thing is I wouldn't
even need to have seen that episode you
were caught on yeah I would have caught
on instantly which is how you know it's
good so yeah um and then Wendy's which
of course was what you'd expect
yeah just like a monster truck let's go
put a plunger on the principal Hindi and
dippers you seen there I'll bet that's
not the real Wendy I know okay as sushi
came in hey Dipper I don't blah blah
blah way if I say I can't said I didn't
know you already saw it so I'm like up
at this at the real Wendy like Oh Oh
aren't you a genius of like it was five
seconds like get to the scene and you're
no no no no oh aren't you smart aren't
you inspire it was way more obnoxious
than that ah
I'm hot I got a gladion right I'm glad
they didn't go that route of actually
showing them the same age cuz eight it
would have been creepy and B there would
have been so much fan art don't know
thing only that scene was creepy enough
as you yeah I'm glad about this right
now today it's like I said we figured it
out so quickly I'm glad they're like
okay we're just dropping this you know
really fast right by the depressing
shores of giggle Creek almost over an
old tree yeah oh how the rock every time
the rock bounces it has a baby Lenny oh
that's why it's called um no I I think
what else I mean the only thing we
really haven't seen that much of is Stan
yet but these obviously they're all
hiding in the in the house there oh I
just realized she was like all these
things I'm realizing now that it's
coming to an end it's like all the
things we're not gonna see we're not
gonna see really a dipper or Pacific
Coast relationship bloom that much
anymore it will also let to do anything
with it it's like oh it's like spin-off
series that could be its own so pop
there you go it'll bake out dipper and
Pacifica um buds days over the Pacifica
um Oh was a dippy fresh really made me
laugh hard um I really hate him
really looks like maybe exact the guy
that we made up for no no you know what
he looks like he really looks like the
Burger King I know you guys yeah that
was the first thing I thought was he
looks like the Burger King kid from the
90s commercials with the with the
freaking glasses I think it was I think
it was intentional like I use aim is
that I'm that and like goofy son Maxo
Callaghan makes between those two I want
to be that insulting to max cuz he
didn't seem dad at night I like it when
um there's just one part where it's like
I mean rather they just say whatever
dippy fresher so you just fence around
the chaise just go like that and I'm
like man what a what a good detail to
pick out boggs I always have ever
changes when such an indictment of the
horrors that was the night I love the
90s bud yeah Danny stupid damn dippy
presh is like Pucci it's like oh we
sorry to get those two together
yeah dippy friend out people that would
unleash Gozer I have refreshing and
fucking Pucci were in the same scene ya
know that's one of my favorite line yeah
it was just such a great just like wow
everything wrong with the 90s in one
character BAM well with Pucci you mean
yeah what is dippy fresh yeah but but
really uh though I do remember that cuz
that was a time where it's like I think
I like what we were saying on the Disney
Afternoon when we were doing the review
the Disney Afternoon we're talking about
how these shows kind of got less and
less as they try to cater more to what
was popular like I think there's a while
where we were even though we weren't
like car to obsess or anything we're
like are we the only ones seeing this is
nobody realize that we're losing really
good creative shows to just pandering
bullshit and then like when that
Simpsons game on is just like thank God
we're not crazy we're not the only ones
that see then it may be the last really
brilliant Simpsons episode like when I
think of like really good Simpsons like
poochie's about the last one I can think
of I was like wow that nailed it mmm
like that was really funny they did go
to the extreme oh but uh but now he's
back on his home planet
haha um but anyway yeah I'll try think I
mean everything about this episode is
kind of self-explanatory I mean it's
Mabel land you can't not enjoy Mabel
it's like the way it ended with the two
of them because of course there's
backlash to Mabel so selfish
Mabel this is like everybody blames for
but look at baby sister selfish oops
well duh it's like when has she not been
selfish that's just kind of Mabel's
thing but the thing is I think they work
together like that's what makes the two
of them work like dipper it malaika's
like I've been seeing this like across
the network some people were just like
oh well now dipper has to give up his
dream and his fantasy of working before
just the satisfy maple stupid sister you
know like he admitted straight up that
he would have been miserable doing it
like being Ford's apprentice no it's one
of those things where it's like it's
it's kind of a mixed bag for me because
on the one hand it's like I don't want
to see those two separate I like to see
him together I think they make a good
team um on the other hand I do think to
myself well okay so he doesn't I believe
a weight says he doesn't really want do
they doesn't wanna you know cuz he had
to think about before and he wasn't sure
so I believe that he doesn't really have
an interesting more especially now that
we're mageddon is happening at all the
answers are there pretty much you know
it doesn't really have any interest of
looking into all this stuff a much RB
with his sister okay so no hold on yeah
but like here's here's the other thing
too is that I'm thinking but why
you know let's grow up together and it's
like you know it granted we're brothers
and stuff like that but you know we move
out we separate at times you know we had
to be away and we live our own lives and
stuff like that and there's other
siblings that we know that move far away
and they're not necessarily like hey we
need to stay glued together but then the
big thing for me is hey they're kids
they're not grown up yet
you know let's their siblings and
they're young and the little kids they
you know they should grow up together
and they should be there for those
important moments and a lot of the
episodes are talking on the royalty well
not only are there kids but I question
Ford's reasoning
behind all this because my issue was
Ford's got shit he's got unresolved with
Stan he wants to separate that and he
wanted to separate those two and
whatever issues Ford had going on with
Stan like that was completely poisoning
the relationship between Mabel and
dipper it was always about dipper you
have to do this dipper you have to do
that
dipper this dipper that well view you
know you can't let Mabel hold you back
like this meant it was always this sort
of thing that was underlining it very
much pretty yeah and if if Stan or if
Ford wanted dipper as an apprentice just
for those noble reasons that's fine but
it was tainted by all that other crap
so dipper would have been doing this and
I think he put it best like I think he
would have been miserable like the thing
is just like Mabel thought she wanted to
be in Mabel land and dipper said no I
know you're smarter than this deep down
you don't really want to be here you
know I think it was the same thing with
dipper I think dipper like was like oh
yeah sure I want to be the apprentice I
want to be the smart one I want to be
this but I think he didn't think it the
whole way through and I think Eddy would
have done it he would have been
miserable I think the one thing I would
like to see a little bit more to
emphasize that because I did get that
but I would have felt a lot stronger if
they show dipper going through a little
bit of that like maybe when he was by
the pond if he was thinking a lot about
that video see it was all there in the
memories that was the whole point of
those scenes was the way they supported
each other because in the same way
dipper was sitting there in Mabel land
and saying you're out of your fucking
mind like this is crazy like this is
your crazy extroverted side you know
completely Unleashed Mabel is always
there to give dipper the push and say no
you're too withdrawn you know go out
live a little so that's the way the two
support each other like what happened it
was dipper crying in the room and then
he gets the Valentines you know she came
in there shoved those Valentines under
and was trying to help a man and have a
supported you know and of course Mabel's
you know issue was all basically kind of
shallow and on the outside but it was
all my hair's messed up so dippers like
well you know we'll do this so it
it really was all there no no it's
something I caught on to it's you know
because there was so much of it two
episodes before you know it and it
seemed like kind of a fast switch but
again I like you said I picked up on it
I picked up at you know hey we're still
young we're kids you know or you know
being siblings is really important let's
still stay together while we're young
and everything you know I did get it I
loved liked a little bit more of him
saying that hey this dream of being with
Ford and find stuff out is not as big a
deal the importance of thing with her is
obvious and that was emphasized I love
like Justin I thought it was pretty
emphasized when he said what I'm gonna
sit here in a lab coat no no you're
right don't buy okay no but four
episodes the whole entire show he's been
obsessed over discovering stuff and with
that one sentence suddenly is kind of
like yeah you know no biggie but like I
said the importance of people ideas also
realized with weirdmageddon that oh this
isn't shits and giggles like this isn't
oh I'm gonna have fun in the basement
like this is fucking insane yeah no I
think he made everything so kind of
found out I mean um um and on top of
that I kind of like that it even though
I love like a little bit more I like
that they did the fast version cuz again
I just wanted more comedy I wanted more
of Mabel land but I want the emotional
center there and I thought that that was
here and I thought you know if there is
a little bit of em missing it you can
you can figure it out like I said they
explained enough where it's like I get
this I understand this oh yeah
Mabel needs dipper to keep her sane and
dipper needs Mabel to keep him sane you
know in their different ways they each
if they're stuck in their own that was
exactly what it was they would have each
been stuck in their own little world and
you know basically the conclusion the
show came to is that they're better off
helping each other out because they
balance each other out yeah so okay
especially given their age um cuz differ
dippers awkward enough as it is I don't
think he needs to be stuck in a basement
for the entire summer like I think I
think one he would have been an extra
push and Mabel is obviously
out of her fucking mind well that's my
that's why I like did you know dipper
needs her dipper needs to bring her back
to reality as well that's right what's
gonna happen with standing for it is
that cuz again I mean Stan is the go out
there and be the showman and stuff like
that and for it is very much though I'm
standing in there Sam's gonna try to go
order yeah I think it's gonna be one of
those things where it's like then they
see how they work each other out like
how different maple did um that'd be my
guess
so uh yeah can't can't take it too much
else just still very very funny very
creative um man second the last episode
that is Mabel's back for one more
episode shut up I'm gonna if yeah I'm
just gonna get like you know a bunch of
popcorn or something when that comes on
yeah cuz that's just gonna be so sad
that's that shit cut off man I you know
what I can't deal with this I'm going to
sweater town is Egypt in there cuz
you're floating on denial it's not just
a river it's a way of life see you next
time
on the last episode